Tuesday lunchtime inside one of London's
most prestigious restaurants normally
this place is packed
today they aren't even serving lunch
just preparing for the evening but
normally obviously if the lunch was
happening this would be we would be in
lunch service now yeah okay yeah the
problem isn't so much demand people
still want to eat out it's that amongst
other things restaurants like this can't
get the staff if I advertise what I get
now is I get four or five CVS from
abroad mostly from the EU
people who I can't employ
if we could have full employment all of
those people would be generating
National Insurance income tax the vat
that you know on the cup of coffee that
you buy on your way to the train station
in the morning
um that all generates wealth and that
wealth is not being generated because we
can't operate at full capacity
extrapolate this across the country and
you start to see why the international
monetary fund is so pessimistic about
the UK's prospects
back in October they thought economic
growth the red bar here would be
somewhere in the middle of the
industrialized pack this year its new
forecasts paint a far gloomier picture
the UK the weakest not just in the
developed world but of any country
mentioned by the fund including Russia
why its Chief Economist says it's partly
those labor shortages partly higher
taxes partly brexit and partly higher
energy costs we've had a very sharp
increase in in natural gas prices Energy
prices in the UK and there is a larger
share of energy that is coming from from
natural gas with a higher pass through
to to final consumers and so that is
affected there's been a stronger cost of
living crisis if you want in uh in the
UK but has the fund gone a bit too far I
think it's a little bit too negative
given the state of the economy it's
saying that the UK will perform at the
bottom of the G7 in those terms I don't
think that's where we're going to sit
we're going to sit in the middle of the
pack now this is just a forecast it'll
probably end up being wrong and it
doesn't change much in practice life the
economy the cost of living crisis it all
goes on as it was pretty much before but
it is awfully awkward for the
governments only a week or two ago the
treasury was saying that the IMF of its
forecast well part of the reason the UK
wasn't alone in facing tough Economic
Times now we are very much alone at the
very bottom of those League tables
on the third anniversary of brexit
Britain is still waiting for the green
shoots of economic recovery and with the
rest of the world now forecast to
recover patience is beginning to run
thin